- Welcome back to Understanding Quantum
Information and Computation.
My name is John Watrous and
I'm the technical director for IBM Quantum Education.
This is the sixth lesson of the series and it's the second lesson in
the second unit of the series, which is on quantum algorithms.
In the previous lesson, we discussed the query
model of computation, and we saw that in that model, quantum algorithms can
provide a striking advantage
over classical algorithms, including an exponential advantage in the case of Simon's problem.
Unfortunately, the query
model doesn't really have any direct or immediate
practical relevance.
The notion of a black box is a very useful
abstraction as it turns out, but we have some work to
do if we're going to apply
the insights that we've
gained from the query model to a more standard computational setting where inputs are given as strings of bits
rather than as oracles or black boxes.
The main purpose of this lesson is to establish a foundation
from which we can do that.
Here's an overview of the lesson. For much of the lesson, we're going to be focusing
on computational cost,
or in other words, how difficult different
computational tasks are and how we can measure that difficulty.
Roughly speaking, this translates to how long we have to wait
for computations to finish and ultimately which
computational problems
we can solve and which
ones are beyond our reach.
We're going to start with
a couple of examples. Integer factorization and computing greatest common
divisors or GCDs for short.
These are very good examples for illustrating the
underlying principles, and they also both happen
to be highly relevant to Shor's algorithm, which we'll
discuss in the next lesson,
so we'll effectively
get double the mileage out of these examples.
Then we'll discuss the notion of computational costs more generally and how we can measure it.
There are many different
ways that this can be done, but we'll focus pretty
narrowly on how we can do this with circuit models of computation,
specifically Boolean circuits
and quantum circuits.
The focus here will be on algorithms as opposed to computer
hardware, for instance, and we'll be more concerned
with how the costs of
running an algorithm scale as the specific problem instances it's run on grow in size rather
than on how many seconds,
minutes, or hours some
particular computation requires.
The idea that motivates this point of view is that algorithms have
fundamental importance.
To this day, we're
still running algorithms that were developed a
very, very long time ago and very naturally, they will be deployed
against larger and
larger problem instances using faster and more reliable hardware as technology develops.
And the way that they scale tells us a great deal
about how useful they are and how useful they'll continue to be.
In the last section of the lesson, we'll turn to a critically important task, which is running classical computations
on quantum computers. The reason this is important is not because we hope to replace classical computers
with quantum computers,
which seems extremely unlikely to happen anytime soon if it ever happens, but rather because it opens up
many interesting possibilities
for quantum algorithms.
Specifically, once we know how to run classical computations
on quantum computers, they become available to quantum
algorithms as subroutines
so we can effectively
leverage everything we know about classical algorithms in the pursuit of quantum computational advantages.
The classical computers that we have today are truly marvels of technology.
They're incredibly fast, but they're not so fast that no computational problem
is beyond their reach.
Some computational problems
are so inherently difficult that although we do have
algorithms to solve them, no computer on the planet Earth today
is fast enough to run these
algorithms to completion on even moderately sized inputs within the lifetime of a human
or even within the lifetime
of the Earth itself.
To explain further, let's take a look at the
integer factorization problem.
The problem statement is very simple. The input to the problem is an integer N that's at least two, and the output is the
prime factorization of N,
and what that means is a list of the prime number factors of N together with the powers that these prime numbers must be raised
in order to get N by
multiplying them all together.
Of course, we can always multiply the prime factors together in any order, but aside from their ordering,
prime factorizations are always unique for every choice of N.
That fact is called the
fundamental theorem of arithmetic, and if you're interested
in learning more about it, it's something that you can find
at the very beginning of
many books on number theory.
As a very simple example, here's the prime factorization
of the number 12.
It's two to the power two
times three to the power one.